[Music]
really something else babe
don't you forget it kept man [ __ ] you
blame me look at her oh I love you so
much
sure I got a lot of problems but my
relationship isn't one was it bad girl
last night wasn't I I just hate thinking
about you being with Ken rents coming up
daddy
you are one sweet piece that ass girl
worth every damn penny just sugar daddy
with a DVD we are in a big old bank
account 68 big ones I usually ain't that
sweet I just wanna make you happy
you know what would make me happy
sixty-eight thousand dollars I've got a
plan and now it likes nothing nobody
gets hurt
relax take a chill pill okay you gotta
Kendra killing me on the floor put your
like never have like hell we are
we've let a woman manipulate you into
murder and kidnapping you gotta learn
how to stand up for yourself can I at
least get off my knees hurt ready to
party chip but that one the best ice
your white boy
it's a hit in the game don't even think
about it skank
[Music]
this is not exactly what I call help the
relationship chip yeah no kidding
[Music]
temple a low
[Music]
[Music]